أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى الاستيلاء الدائم أه بعيد
ونعتقد أن أه أه هذه الوضعيات أه
إطعام أطفالنا لبضعة أيام
ومن ثم استئناف قتلهم هي
أخبار جيدة أن أه أه
الرهائن أه سيتم إطلاق سراحهم أه من
الجانبين أه  وبينما
يشيد العالم بالإفراج عن 50
رهينة إسرائيلية، فهو أمر جيد بالنسبة لهم، لا أحد يتحدث
عن مئات
الأطفال الفلسطينيين الذين سيتم إطلاق سراحهم والذين
احتجزتهم إسرائيل كرهائن حتى قبل
السابع من أكتوبر وحتى قبل السابع
من أكتوبر، لذا فإن هذا  هي فرصة
لفضح نظام
الهيمنة العنصرية الفاسد والعفن الذي أقامته إسرائيل
في كامل أراضيها، حسنًا
للإسرائيليين كل فلسطيني
إرهابي للإسرائيليين كل
إنسان يدعم حقوقنا أه
كل من يدعو إلى إنهاء حقوقنا
الاحتلال معاد للسامية أه
أطفالنا أطفال يستحقون الحب
الحماية يستحقون
مستقبل مختلف ولم يسبق في التاريخ أن
رأينا يحاصر الأطفال دون تهمة
دون محاكمة دون الوصول إلى
والديهم أو حتى المحامين هذه
وحشية